hello everyone and welcome to a
remarkable game from the World Cup 2009
it comes as a suggestion uh from a
person uh that goes by the name of
solico or solico so thank you for
recommending such a wonderful game it's
a game from round three of the world
coming 2009 and it is Yuri Polgar versus
the body's girlfriend now it is of
course a well-known fact that Boris
girlfriend won the 2009 World Cup he
defeated the Russian polynomario in the
finals I was a really a brutal fight
then he proceeded uh to go into the
candidates Tournament of 2011 where he
defeated
in the first match gatakamski in the
second match and then he faced Alexander
grichuk in the third match that he also
won so he won the candidates tournament
in 2011 and that led him all the way to
the uh match for the world chair
championship title against the den
Champion vishwanathan Anna now I'm gonna
spoil too much uh but uh that's pretty
much all well known but this game uh not
that well known uh a girlfriend that
defeated Judith Polgar in the in round
three of uh the the World Cup but uh he
did not win this game he uh lost this
one he retaliated in the second one and
then he won in Rapid time format but um
yeah this is a real Beauty and it could
very easily be overlooked so I'm very
much grateful for this wonderful
suggestion it's a beautiful attacking
game uh I mean you will if you didn't
know you was playing this you would
probably think mikalta was playing this
so so let's check it out we have Pawn to
E4 by unit as she is an E4 player we
have Pawn to E5 and Bishop to C4 she
goes for The Bishop's opening Knight to
F6 and now Pawn to D3 so sort of a
London system without actually playing
D4 uh we have C6 Queen to E2 and now
Bishop to E7 we have Knight to F3 uh
Boris castles and now Bishop back to B3
the bishop will be much safer here as
you know the D5 can be played at any
point so you don't have to uh react to
uh to do harshly on that uh we have Pawn
to these six castles and Knight B to D7
we have Fawn to C3 and A5 preparing to
further Advance the pawn uh so upon the
A4 stopping that and pawn to B5 now and
it is not as of move nine that this
position has never been reached again
with Bishop back to C2 and now Bishop to
A6 so it can be can be very annoying as
your queen and the Rook are on this
diagonal so you might want to do
something thing about that but first
eight captures on B5 C captures on B5
and not Knight B to D2 We have Queen to
C7 and now Pawn to D4 we have A4 uh you
if you play B4 yes we've already said
this is um a very annoying but you can
block with C4 you can play Bishop to D3
so black doesn't actually win any
material here so instead we have Pawn to
A4 uh and now Bishop to D3 uh uh getting
ready to put pressure on this bishop
here uh we have Rook F to B8 the body
says this game will not be played on the
king side it will be played on the queen
side and a little bit in the center but
unit says I don't agree with that this
game will be played on the king side as
pretty much all of the games that she
plays are played wherever your uh her
opponent uh King is so G6 is taking away
the F5 Square from the White Knight and
now Pawn to F4 and look at this e
captures an F4 and she plays Knight the
D to F3 just re-maneuvers her Knight and
getting ready to pick up that
temporarily sack of Pawn but Boris says
let's make it a permanent sacrifice
let's not call it a temporary Pawn
sacrifice and he just defends his Pawn
he plays Knight to H5 defends the pawn
and he says all right where is uh where
is this counter play for this uh
sacrifice pawn and okay she plays Bishop
to D2 just continuing to develop Knight
to B6 and now how do you continue well
she plays Pawn to G for now uh he
already took one bite and now if he
wants to continue enjoying his extra
Pawn he's gonna have to play F captures
and G3 up a song Because if the Knight
goes back then she will just capture
back the pawn and she will have a strong
Center without actually having to
sacrifice anything for creating such a
wonderful position so he accepts the G
characters uh F characters and G3 Alpha
Song and of course it is the strongest
move recommended by the engine but now
not capturing back Knight to G5 and now
you're already uh starting to understand
what kind of a player you Polgar uh who
was and and still is I mean not too long
ago she defeated Magnus Carlsen in the
park uh
so uh yeah like like I said like
watching uh like watching Michael tal
play basically and now if G captures an
H2 uh it's it's possible but after Queen
captures you just give white a bit too
much even if you trade everything Bishop
captures Bishop captures and B4 you want
to trade off the light Square Bishops as
well let's say characters captures then
comes Knight to F5 and uh White is just
better here there is no no question
about it you cannot capture as the
Knight here is hanging and it's just a
great great uh piece uh if black really
wants to prove that black is better
black will have to play F6 here and then
it's uh well then it's just anyone's
game so after Knight G5 we have Knight
to C4 here and now comes Knight to F5
here
and Knight the C4 is actually a mistake
there is a there is a beautiful win here
for for you but uh look at this Rook
captures on F7 and okay Boris did allow
the captron F7 the idea is after Knight
captures on D2 you ignore this and now
you play Knight to F5 and now if you
don't want to get a brutally checkmated
with something like Knight to H6 check
followed by Rook captures on H7 you have
to play G captures on H2 check King H1
and now you have to give up the Queen
Bishop captures on G5 and after after
everything gets traded off Rook captures
on C7 now Rook to B7 you want to get rid
of this Rook here captures captures uh a
queen to G4 only moved uh really give
why the advantage as it puts pressure on
the bishop Bishop F4 and now just Knight
captures on D6 Bishop captures on D6
Queen to E6 with check nicely connecting
with the bishop and after the king moves
Queen captures on D6 and after all is
said and done uh yes okay this looks a
bit uh difficult for for white but the
the the bishop although on a fine
diagonal can't really do all that much
it's basically two Knights versus a
queen and a unit would be completely
winning here she went for it uh with a
bit of a different move order instead of
going in a rook captures on F7 right
away she first plays Knight to F5 and
now what's the problem with Knight to F5
right away as you also uh you've seen it
being played in the previous line well
now bodies can play Bishop captures on
G5 Bishop captures and now Pawn to F6
and the attack is pretty much gone so
why did she allow this well who knows
Bishop to H4 G captures on H2 and now
Queen captures on H2 and now in order to
play this you again have to find very
unique moves you can't just capture the
Knight if you capture the Knight then
Rook captures on F5 and now
okay the Knight is hanging here Knight
to G7 Bishop captures on F6 Knight
captures on F5 and now e captures on F5
and although it looks really weird
you're actually your position is
actually uh brilliant here for example
Queen F7 You're Gonna Play Queen to H4
defend your bishop and black will have
to find miraculous ways to defend King
F2 and Rook to G1 it's not gonna be easy
although although it is possible but
okay after Queen captures on H2 Rook the
f8 was played board is not one to be
tricked he's easily like he finds the
absolute best move uh Bishop to E2 now
preparing the capture and now we have G
captures on F5 again uh bodies plays
with uh with engine light precision the
problem is if you go back with the
Knight I would just show it because it's
a classical and it is a beautiful line
uh Bishop captures in C4 Queen captures
and now look at this Knight the E7 with
check and I'm sure you guys are already
seeing the patterns here uh if King to
h8 which I mean you have to play if you
go here
uh than just real captors on F6 you go
under the mask of the bishop that
resigns so King to h8 now Bishop
captures an F6 and if Rook to F7 now
comes Knights the G6 with checking to
Jade Knight the E7 with check King to h8
and now of course The Sensational Rook
F2 and black resigns here you do not
want to even see what uh happens next uh
as it's I mean it's not for the uh you
know for for the for a timid Soul uh for
example if you play anything then you
are met with Queen captures an H7 check
as the Knight and Bishop are covering
all of these squares and after King
captures The Rook to HD check will be
Checkmate okay you can block one check
but then what captures will be Checkmate
so you just get absolutely destroyed
here so what is plays the absolute best
mode G captures on F5 now it's
definitely time to capture that piece
Bishop captures an H5 and now F captures
an E4 and this is uh uh the the
basically the first mistake of the game
and the one that Boris should never have
um uh done the problem is you have to
play Queen to G7 you have to find Bishop
B7 and queen to G7 uh but you also have
to understand that it's actually
possible to hold this with black for
example King to H1 Bishop to B7 grabs
hold of this diagonal you can block it
with the D5 but then you just move the
queen queen to E7 and now you see the
problem D for uh Pawn is hanging and
there's nothing white can do to prevent
um uh losing it so yeah that's the
problem even if you play something like
this then you open up this diagonal once
again so that was the way to go however
after F captures an E4 it seems like an
even better idea because it seems like
you will just you know start pushing
those pawns now you just Place Queen to
F4 and what's the problem with this uh
well you could play Queen D7 sure if
Queen t7 and then everything just gets
traded off and then we just uh I played
this uh this end game with you being a
little bit better but Ponte F5 was
played by Boris and now uh there is no
way to hold on to everything but it's
really really funny why there's only one
line that wins for you that and you guys
of course will help her find it King to
each one we have King to h8 sidestepping
Rook to G1 check but still Rook to G1
and now of course what is happening here
uh the trick is okay if Bishop to B7 you
might have some checks here might um you
know it looks pretty good problem is
Queen to H6 and now with E3 check you're
gonna play King H2 and if D5 check
you're just gonna play King H3 and there
is uh no defense either Bishop to F6
will be winning or if you try to move
the queen to somehow defend the F6
Square then just Queen to G7 will be
Checkmate so you cannot defend against
both of these uh threats it's just game
over so Boris of course finds a defense
he plays Rook to F7 but now look at this
bishop captures on F7 now not the only
to grab material but also to prepare a
brutal uh brutal end of the game Queen
captures an F7 and now Queen to H6 the
thread of course is Bishop to F6 check
and the blacking will have nowhere to go
bodies will have to give up is Queen so
there is only one move that stops this
Rook to f8 but now even though it seems
the body stop the attack feel free to
pause the video and try to find an
absolutely crushing idea for you did uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for a fine way to end the attack and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course Rook to G6 this is
what you displayed and it was in this
position on move 32 that body's
girlfriend resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here of
course uh if you capture the or you
cannot capture with the pawn if you
capture with if you don't capture Bishop
to F6 it's just game over if you capture
uh then Queen captures an f8 you have to
block and then bishop and F6 which
delivers Checkmate as the queen is
pinned by the by the White Queen on f8
and if you don't do that after Rook to
G6 what else could you do let's say
Knight to E3 now just start collecting
Bishop F6 check Queen characters through
captors through captors Queen captures
with check and okay I mean it's Queen
and Rook versus a knight and Bishop not
really something to look forward to you
will deliver one check after an ig4 you
capture knife Falls next and that's
pretty much it so absolutely brilliant
brilliant game by udit Polgar and round
three of the World Cup 2009 uh what is
retaliated with the black pieces
um uh so sorry with the white pieces in
the next game and he was able to take no
he retaliated with the white pieces and
then he was able to take a win in in the
rapid section uh and like I said he
continued all the way to the finals
defeated Pony Mario then he went into
the candidates Tournament of 2011 he
defeated first Mohamed yard then he
defeated gatakomski then uh Alexander we
shook in the finals and then he
proceeded to face vishwanathan Anand in
their wheelchairs championship match
where it was uh you know uh uh anyone
could have taken it they've traded uh
one set of blows and then uh pretty much
at the end of the of the match on and
one one more game and then uh Island won
the uh even by uh by one point margin so
it was a pretty good run for Boris he
almost had it but not quite Anand was
there to to stop him uh but yeah that
does not uh prevent excellent
subscribers from digging up beautiful
games like these and sending them to me
so I can share them with everyone so
once again really thank you for that I
would like to thank Christoph mark an
anonymous person uh all the games are
best Lynn Herbert and Seth Harper for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh uh a new
World Cup is coming up very soon so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day